let's go next to uh let's go to skyler
from new york
skyler from new york you're on the air
hey can you hear me sort of you're
you're kind of cutting in and out
how about now is it any better that is
better awesome
um well thanks so much for calling me um
my question
is how do we dispel the notion that
progressive policies cost the democrats
in the house and the senate
well who who's arguing that
like for example uh the moment that you
know the associated press called the
election for biden you've got john
kasich on cnn
saying that you know they almost cost
the democrats the election
and that biden needs to cater to the
center which is what
most of america is despite every exit
poll showing
overwhelming uh majority favoritism
towards these progressive policies like
whether it's legalizing marijuana
or raising the minimum wage or even fox
news showing like 70 percent of people
supporting a government-funded health
care system
yeah well so i think you so what's
interesting is the one example you cited
of people saying that is a republican
anyway so i don't really worry too much
about that i mean i think
i i've heard a little bit of a debate
within the left
about did the democrats run too far
left or too far right in the house and
senate i don't think there's one answer
to that i think that we need to stop
that that general question is the wrong
question because
there are districts in which it is
completely reasonable to run more to the
left
and then there are districts and seats
where that would not work
uh as much as i dislike joe manchin in
west virginia who is the most
conservative democratic
senator i have not seen any data that
suggests
a progressive running in west virginia
would win because west virginia
democrats are different than democrats
in other places so i just think it's an
it's too simplistic of an argument
i think you have to be looking more more
specifically at individual races and
states and realizing that
country of 331 million people that's
this size there's no
anybody who says the problem is
democrats ran too far left
or the problem is democrats ran too far
right it's too simplistic of an
assertion
hello oh i think you got me remuted
there somehow are you there
uh yeah i did get renewed sorry about
that no problem
um yeah i mean like i just saw a clip of
jim clyburn saying that defund the
police cost
jamie harrison's seat despite uh the
widespread
protests in black lives matter and that
whole movement
actually is what initially saw jamie
harrison
uh surge in the polls yeah not only that
i mean
defund the police was something that was
mostly pushed on democrats by the right
there are some democrats talking about
defund
most are not most are talking about
reform reorganize
restructure rethink and i i was one of
them i mean the
defund the police was mostly a smear in
the sense of what was actually being
proposed at the national level
i know and why is it that you know
democrats are unable to work outside
these right-wing
framing and talking points like uh
anybody that actually takes like a
nuanced perspective on this
understands you know what what you mean
when you say something like defund the
police but
it just seems like republicans have a
more effective way of
uh you know smearing and grifting their
base and controlling the branding and
the messaging and the democrats
are often playing defense instead of
getting out in front of these things i
basically agree with you
but the the one thing you did say which
i think is a fault of the left
is you say you know most people
understand what defund the police really
means
i've been saying for a while if you
don't mean defund don't call it defund
call it what it what it actually is and
that that i think is a fair criticism
uh but but for the most part again it's
been a smear from the right attributed
to democrats
and uh you're thinking of all the right
things you you were just muted
i don't know i don't know how this
caller keeps getting getting muted i'm
not muting them
but i appreciate the call and um i hope
to hear from you again that's uh
a server mute kept appearing on that
caller and
there's only a few people with the
permissions that would make that happen
so i think we should try to understand
uh why why that
that was happening that's very very
strange our sponsor purevpn is having a
huge black friday sale right now they're
giving you
88 office subscription which comes out
to only a little over a dollar a month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online and you can trust them
because they're the only vpn in the
industry with an
always third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged by hiding your ip address purevpn
keeps you safe
from hackers and prevents you from being
spied on by your internet service
provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than
any other vpn in the industry everyone
should be using a vpn when connecting to
the internet and now is the perfect time
to start because purevpn is giving you
an 88
discount on a subscription which comes
out to only a little over a dollar a
month
go to davidpakman.com purevpn
the link is underneath the video